en ukraine la russie espérait que la
guerre ne dure que quelques jours
mais la résistance ukrainienne a déjoué
les plans de poutine notamment inquiets
british energy
risk of the world
face à ces déconvenues un homme à la
réputation sulfureuse a été nommé pour
diriger l'ensemble des opérations son
surnom le boucher de syrie alors qui est
il quelles sont ses méthodes la réponse
dans facture
cet homme récompensé par vladimir
poutine c'est alexandre devant nicole ce
jour là le 16 mars 2016 il est décoré
héros de la fédération de russie
la raison son implication dans la guerre
en syrie aux côtés de bachar al assad
âgé de 60 ans ce général est né au temps
de l'union soviétique
bien loin de moscow à oussouriisk sur ce
personnage très peu d'informations
personnelles sont connus il a par poker
assez classique qui sort de l'école
militaire dans les années 80 au temps de
l'urss et après il poursuit une carrière
normale classique en commission les
échelons son premier fait d'armes il
l'acquiert entre 1999 et 2000 c'est la
prise de grosse pendant la seconde
guerre de tchétchénie
il est intervenu pour reprendre la
capitale sans que l'on ne connaisse son
implication exact ici l'armée russe a
imposé un siège pendant plus d'un mois
et a massivement bombardé la ville ils
appliquaient des ordres qui monnaient
d'ailleurs et des facteurs techniques de
bombarder les villes de les raser c'est
quelque chose qui est malheureusement
classique est qui et qui existe dans la
doctrine
militaires russes donc c'est pas propre
à lui mais ses propres si à la façon
dont les russes peuvent mener ou savent
mener la guerre s'il n'était alors pas
aux commandes sa réputation
internationale il va l'acquérir quinze
ans plus tard
alors que le régime de bachar al-assad
subi un mouvement d'opposition pro
démocratie puis une guerre contre l'état
islamique la russie lui vient en aide en
septembre 2015 n'oublions pas de risques
inutiles
et brighi menace terroriste jusqu'à
microsoft connaît porter jusqu'au bout
d'une astuce let's twist
malgré
l'envié
à la tête de ses opérations russe
alexandre zhoukov surnommé le boucher de
ses surnoms qu'on trouve essentiellement
en occident ça vient de la violence avec
laquelle les russes ont mené la guerre
en syrie et donc la technique qui est
employé es salaam effectivement c'est de
bombarder des villes avec en piégeant
les gens en exerçant son double discours
pour laisser des gens partir mais en
vain depuis dans les corridors bref une
technique là aussi très meurtrière après
la syrie le général dornic off est nommé
aux commandes des forces du district
militaire sud l'un des plus importants
du pays est depuis l'invasion en ukraine
il est en charge des opérations au sud
et dans le donbass là où les troupes
russes progress le mieux contrairement à
kiev où le kremlin a refusé de bombarder
massivement ici on a pu voir des
stratégies militaires similaire à la
syrie un art you parce qu'il va
absolument cet objectif militaire pour
ce colloque corridor côtier entre la
crimée held on passe là bas il n'a pas
eu le choix en tout cas il a mis tous
les moyens et tous les moyens en russe
ça veut dire y compris à bombarder d'une
manière indiscriminée mais depuis le 10
avril alors que la russie a échoué à
prendre kiev c'est lui que poutine a
nommé à la tête de cette guerre n'est
assez surprenante il n'y a pas en tout
cas à la connaissance des occidentaux
deux commandants de théâtre depuis le
début des opérations spéciales comme
comme on dit en russie donc ça c'est à
son défaut d'organisation
il a fallu corriger et remédier il
fallait un chef et pourquoi lui pas tant
à cause de la syrie en fait mais parce
que déjà c'est à des plus depuis grade
est un des plus anciens officiers de
l'armée russe dont il a de l'expérience
parce qu'il est en charge
du district militaire sud et donc de la
zone crimée et théâtre séparatiste où se
déroulent les combats aujourd'hui donc
il connaît la zone il commence à faire
la guerre
lui ou un autre la guerre va rester
violentes et meurtrières et intérêts
sont poutine pas rester total pour
pousser malgré les échecs malgré deux
revers barricades à la folie de la
guerre
c'est pas
ce général qui changent les choses après
est ce que dans la conte militaire il
aura moins de scrupules c'est aussi
difficile a dit les précédents depuis le
début du conflit il ya pas eu beaucoup
de scrupules à bombarder marioupol ou
d'autres
région sans doute que en choisissant ce
boucher de syrie poutine en voici un
message quand même la population les
occidentaux pour montrer sa
détermination à parvenir à un objectif
un résultat par tous les moyens
possibles